the long-awaited horse is here
thunderhorse one-minute war zone rated
59 players so far there's a maximum of
150 average rating 1745 time and
position will be adjusted according to
players as ratings in order to balance
things out at 30 minutes ending from now
anybody could play if you're on just
cube here we go
actually there's an entry fee of 20 but
anyhow no level requirement here we go
Queen side minor pieces get developed
start off with here that's okay you can
do it you can do it I'm going to go with
this I'm not sure why but I'm gonna do
it let's go my Kings gonna have to run
for the hills let's go here right now
let's go wait me to see these next moves
you ready I need to see him oh there's
nothing good Oh for karu ski I got one
of the pieces back I got one if I'm back
chop-chop-chop my knight is pinned hit
the Queen no I wasn't hitting the Queen
that's it the Queen now whew what do we
got hit the Queen again ah she must be
scared
hit it again pawn push tricky tricky huh
there's not a fork there's not a fork
I'm on the Queen
oh I'm getting pieces back now it's the
only thing I have to do is what time oh
I got the Queen I should take it to
Queen Oh
take the knight everything's falling
team black is falling apart
I got h6 double up double trouble kill
the bishop give me no I have me just
close to me pin pin ruski I got the
Queenie how much time there's plenty of
time plenty of time you could do this
maybe in 1 2 3
check where's the mate
this is check gobble this guy up mate
next there's me okay I should have done
it sooner - to a lot of two's okay let's
go here let's go let's roll double the
points yes I'm only down a night
whenever they robbed me of both minor
pieces that's brutal
oh is that brutal or what here we go be
prepared be scared White be prepared to
be scared oh man I have no idea what I'm
talking about okay my Knights dead there
goes my whole plan without my knight I
have nothing defend King No
okay I might have had to do that if the
was pressure on that okay wait a second
I got if that file let me take this
because my bishops gonna look stupid if
I did that right away let's not look
stupid and no double up on the F file
rook right here is a good start
my queen well let's do this before I
move my rook their bishops kind of okay
oh I didn't want to do that oh I want to
cry again I want to cry I want to cry oh
man I didn't want to do that that was a
mouse slipper hit the Queen kill the
bishop kill the bishop go after the
bishop is the bishop dead it's dead it's
dead it's a dead man oh the night is a
little tricky over here ah man I want to
kill that night I want to get f7 f7 f7
f7 never seven can you see it have 700
their definitive seven Queen you need to
go somewhere else I need to chase you
away they only have 10 seconds kill the
Queen they could take my rook and push
kill the Queen
kill the Queen I'm on the Queen I should
just take it let's try it again the gold
there right no oh that was a good that
was a good Mouse lip otherwise it would
last my god six is okay I'm up there
oh no Queen rook no Queen rook for you
you will play oh I just dropped my
bishop oh did I plan that no I didn't
plan it
I didn't plan that one you never planned
for dropping pieces do you they're
having fun with that um the dark squares
okay give me the rug give me the rope
give me the rope give me the rook Oh
drop my knight give me that bishop for
the rook
give me a bishop or your rook one of the
two I'm gonna hang on to my tricky night
I love my tricky Knights he's tiny
burner he's a potential time burner
let's come over here before you get
trapped night time burner and I'm on the
Queen time burn around the Queen I got
the Queen oh no I don't know I don't I'm
setting it up
h7 sneaky moves oh let's do this I'm
very nervous right now
very nervous oh man 22 seconds let's go
night post up post Oh
Knight g3 no okay get out of there
Knight Bishop right here h7 h7 eighties
got to go over here over here right
mates
I'm on the Brooke I'm on the night I
want to get to f6 you're gonna take that
night just take tonight
maybe I'm down a rook okay you could do
it no you stay around stay around do
something ten seconds come on you gotta
get this come Oh Forks I should've did a
fork
I want a fork fork I got him I got the
brook come on just go quick go quick go
quick
on the night be very scared I'm on the
night I got the night come on come on
come on come I come upon how much second
I'd have any time there's no such thing
wait how much time
Oh Oh what's that's me
oh oh that's me I was looking to see
what was down a time that was a double
checkmate as I promoted oh man I was
holding my breath right there oh man oh
that was crazy
oh I took the wind right out of me it's
good thing I'm carved up though I'm
carved up
I prepared before this tournament they
have no idea my opponents have no idea
the preparation I took before I started
this I was carving up like it was an
Ironman contest Wow
let's go here Queen d2 queenside castle
launched th pond you know it's about
let's launch him he's in launched
engaged ah okay
sneak attack keep it closed Oh an
in-betweener
the deadly in-betweener bishop here
Oh Knight right there is everything all
right is it gonna be okay
Queens are coming up Oh scary time scary
time it's scary time here I want to get
on c2 how much time do they have they're
running out of time that's a good thing
ah there's Knight check oh that's a
killer yes it is oh boy what can you do
right now
avoid Queen exchanges for starters let's
set up tricky tactics where are the
tricky tactics Queen to c5 be very
scared listen to me oh let's do 15
they're not moving please let it be
their clock that's moving right now okay
it is I got me oh that was a help mate
I'm gonna take the helm aids 20 points
okay a lot of time left
oh these are the tough ones these are
tough these are tough I got the f7 pondo
a quick eight f7 pawn attack
oh the Bishop's gonna kill me you got to
go bishop I can't tolerate you I can't
tolerate you bishop oh he's gonna be
giving me a beating really soon oh man
give you that light square bishop oh I
have this covered this is good this is
good this is good right is the night
gonna go there I have pressure on f7
what am i doing
castle and then do what get over here
actually no no there's nothing going on
over there actually there's something
here pile up on the C pond that's the
plan is there gonna be a pond push there
might be Queen here looks good I'm on
that B pun what's the time situation
okay I think we're doing all right
Queen takes B G for g5 that's very
committal oh my bishops gonna get hit oh
it's getting hit man okay I guess we'll
do this okay push push again B five my
LightSquared Bishop e5 we're not evil
it's time quit hittin my queen what did
I do to deserve that
Oh dark square weaknesses uh painful
painful stuff g3 I got to do let's do it
anyhow
I should have taken that pond that's too
late it's too late you lost your um you
lost your chance there okay I gotta open
all this up I guess sneaky move I'm
gonna do sneaky move coming up sneaky
sneaky sneaky haha I had to try it it
was a time burner at the very least time
burners I don't want the Queen's off the
board oh there's gonna be a rip move Oh
there's gonna be rook moved there could
have been
could've been a sac could have taken my
rook they have no time out of time yes
back to term in 30 40 3 30 30 30
kay Hampton to to to to who can have a
resigner Hampton yes back to tournament
killer 4342 okay Hampton
I think Hampton is a resigner all right
I want to play against Hampton come on
oh I didn't move I was waiting to what
am I waiting for
it was my move I just lost a ton of time
right there okay let's get to the setup
you know and love and this is the setup
you know in love right here oh those
were precious seconds right there get
out of there bishop
okay you got to do this here we go
launch them launch them gee file okay
anyone drop that pun queenside castle f4
here we go f4 is on the cards my bishop
is around to defend stuff isn't it I got
to do it even if it's wrong no I need my
bishop around to defend my king said
open it up I'm in trouble if you didn't
realize I'm in trouble right now oh I'm
in big trouble I'll take a pun is this
okay to do hit the knight God that pond
I'm gonna hide behind their pond if they
take no what is that doing there's gonna
be a night check Oh very scary come here
before it's too late
oh okay wait they can't go to the corner
can't go to the corner just yet I got b5
my bishops kicked around the Knights
gonna come here what's happening I got a
double up how much time seventies and
seconds oh man oh man what am i doing
with that move no I just dropped my
bishop take my rook take my rook with
your pan yes or that that's good - oh my
got the Queen it could be me real soon
me I want to keep this close a little
bit hit the night hit the night I'm on
the pond no I can't take that pin
how much time six seconds go quick push
up on then all the Knights gonna move
and kill me he's killing me I'm dead my
paint my queen oh oh no oh man it's dead
I'm a dead man I'm a dead man
stalemates there's no stamp it's a dead
man ah that was ugly ugly why'd you lose
that one you idiot oh man I should have
had that that's all right that's all
right I'm winning this I'm coming back
there's 16 minutes left I'm going down
swinging there's no way I'm not gonna go
out swing in here let's see you could do
it don't you dare give up
don't you dare over here oh man I better
move my bishop before it's too late
actually I better do this and get my
Knight to f4 there we go give me the G
file G file G file you got this you got
this break it open
kill the knight queenside castle made on
the H file looking for mates mates
coming up
where are they take that pawn and then
give mate next okay we got made threats
o take the pawn that was a mouse lip I
can't afford these Mouse lips here I'm a
knight the pawns are gonna push ah yes
mate back to term in 54 don't count me
out I lost in the last tournament one of
those games but I came back guess who
came back I came back here we go
don't count me out don't count the
chickens on it uh uh they were being
sneaky 92 g4 night g3 and accelerated
thunderhorse variation here we go
g4 to g5 I really don't want exchanged
let's not actually I probably have to oh
boy
can I get this pawn at least there's
gonna be Bishop here and pawn push and
stuff oh boy
let me take this hopefully it's okay
Queen trade I'm down a rook though I
can't go for Queen trade oh the Queen
roll I can't even castle castling is out
the door oh boy oh man the position is
opening up not a good thing for me oh
man oh man oh I just dropped another
rook oh this is just too much
is there any save can it be saved oh
please let it be saved I'm gonna be
sneaky an escape hatch they didn't
expect this an escape hatch for the king
watch me pull a fast one here escape
hatch you gotta look for the escape
hatches they're there their time is
tickin
twenty seconds my King has fast legs
he has very fast legs let's go he's
gonna flee to the beat three square flee
to be treason the plan oh no I couldn't
take the rook let's stop that I'm on the
rook watch where you go Queen bad things
can happen if you go too far away oh I
made it I'm close to mated I made it no
no I was mated I was made a queen check
just go here and then here I was mated
there was Queen check and then rook to
f3 and stuff Oh check never suspect that
one time burner banks tournament oh man
the panic you have no idea how panicked
I was on that one okay
these are so tough or they tough or what
alright what do you do when you're down
this material here Oh check take the
knight please let me have a center okay
I want to hang on to my light square
bishop okay wait a second I might
actually like to be able to launch a
fishing pole
no we're a fishing pole stop this
advanced fishing pole out of nowhere
he's got to go opposite color bishops
okay wait a second this is good
I want to target this G pun so here we
go this is how it's gonna happen this is
how it's gonna go down hit the G pun get
the H pun uh-oh
be very scared uh-oh I'm on it three
times what's this rope doing he's a
clown over here get doing something
actually my H pond wants to do something
first let's get out of that now that it
wasn't pinned clean to g3 I should have
played mmm oh the rook is dead pond push
ok now this rook is gonna play he's
gonna have some fun
oh why did they do that they weren't
supposed to do that
oh okay open it up over here oh man did
they Mouse slip and it just happened to
be a good thing oh you know what uh uh
what am i doing man 23 seconds on have
any time uh come on looking for me I'm
on the bishop if they move the rook I
got the bishop yes I got the bishop at
least come on time time to time or even
untie my Rick is sneaky sneaky rook
guard upon look for the how am i trying
to say look for the sneaky moves is what
I'm trying to say get active rook no I
didn't want to do that I want to give
check ah okay this is good though oh I
didn't want to do that King and pawn
endgame no let's avoid it I like my rook
keep a rook on the board cut your King
off I'm gonna cut your King off check
free meal free move pre moves
I went pretty moves check pre move pre
move
check oh what's happening here
okay I got to do this I got to be sneaky
pre-move how much time they're out
pretty moving me it was almost the adobe
flash gambit sneaky yes they forfeited
back on time are they there back to
tournament they're out of time this is
gonna be a tough one man
I'm getting paired up with these big
dogs here
oh fishing pole land fishing pole land
engaged okay I have a center at least oh
we might be seeing it
h4 they're gonna challenge that pun
right I got it take the pond take the
pond take the pond they're not taking
the pond okay you could still do this
right
clean up clean up to e4 oh I'm gonna do
it anyhow do I have this Oh be very
scared be very scared it's happening
let's go Queen give a check on h7 and
then take on f7 or something
let's guard this
there's nothing here right okay run away
King and I got a defense stuff I
definitely have to defend stuff check I
could block here rook up and over how
about okay there is no taking here
because I have a check okay I have a lot
of pieces take the knight oh oh oh okay
this is scary
oh no I want to get to g6 this is still
no good because I have a bishop check I
got to get out of this pin it's it's bad
King to g1 actually there would be
something like that
okay my queen is getting hit I have a
lot of time though I have a time edge
King to g1 their time is tickin my rook
is dead that's all right
just want their clock to burn they're
not they're not moving fast this is good
this is good time burners I could throw
in some time burners check check check
time burners more time burners back to
tournament 108 130 to 125 seven minutes
and change uh okay I'm out of night on
this one oh man
let's go Bishop g7 right here he's got
to go away I should have done this okay
not f5 and then yeah let's do this I
guess and then queenside castle I guess
chase that around and then get this in I
want to get to h4 that h4 pun ah okay I
got to support this I think I have to
watch over the e4 square pawn push trap
the bishop close to trapping the bishop
is it trapped really close to being
trapped no they can take this pot I
could get this one though maybe okay I
have each for my bishops dead light
square bishop stead but let's come over
here where oh this move is a killer
isn't it oh they should be very scared
right okay they got a sac that bishop
and actually I have something sneaky no
I don't I thought there was something
with like rook check and then Bishop
takes Knight there might have been
actually let me do this I'm on the night
and what else oh this is a killer making
one if the King moves make sure this de
Maintenon
132 129 128 six minutes and change I'm
up there come on super bulbs go down
here let's go let's roll come on come on
you got a burn time here
stop Bishop to b5 get in this okay we
have the setup we want no exchanges now
where are you gonna go King where you
gonna go okay you're over here I'm
coming after you
I'm coming after you no trades don't you
dare
so now the Knights need to find new
homes oh here comes a nice home for the
night okay I got to watch over this
square the Knights ready to go there
okay actually they're not uh taking this
into account okay maybe they are oh okay
Knight - right here no right here
otherwise the Knights gonna play there I
gotta get this move in he's got to go oh
my queen is dead oh she's dead she's a
dead woman no she's not okay
oh right there she was definitely
running out of squares okay
that night was really good now I'm gonna
kick now I get here the King's gonna
flee isn't he is the king gonna flee
okay take this pond leading to mate or
something
mmm okay I need to get my other doing
something and play rook here then King
here and then get the other ruck over
this is good though this is definitely
good look at the time edge time edge
pre-move time
Premal time anything actually that's
actually a good move right now there's
your pen
there's no time to figure it out though
prema prema prema give a check and I get
that rug actually back to termen 148
who's in first Oh what 48 I told you not
to count me out who's counting me out
don't you dare shame on you if you were
cutting me out I have it lead let's go
43 seconds oh let's go let's here I
don't know what this night moon was
doing no no trades the bishop just stuck
his head out for a second he's like oh
okay and then he ran back home okay
no take this night if anything actually
let's go like this this is better I
think no let's go like what's going on
of the above none of the above it's my
opponent who doesn't want to trade now
okay
Queen here oh the night's gonna kill me
or not um they're floundering my
opponents floundering they're trying
they're struggling for a plan I got to
get rid of okay right here right here
King up rook here or something can I get
this that all the Knights gonna kill me
isn't it my punish be making use of this
square for a night I don't know why
they're not okay now I have this dark
square bishop okay kick that night away
it's running out of squares isn't it
whoa here we go and then take that light
square bishop I guess over here I want
to get to me right here back rank main
issues I'm on that uh rook kill the
knight actually let's do this and push
and I get this Knight next
let me take this night first and then
take here I should have done that that
ponds dead oh this is leading to Maine
made they resigned back to tournament
168 159 two minutes and change this is
not an easy tournament it's not easy
being down pieces to start and time not
easy at all this is like the
anti-authority they're preparing okay I
can take a nap DuPont push okay now it's
at least closed right here that was
probably my lip I know the feeling
definitely know the feeling okay
I want my night to be where oh he can
never get to that square canny okay
where does he want to be then oh he
doesn't want to be there oh no no no no
wow dodged the bull he's going back
there though the area's okay we're gonna
have a lot of moving back and forth
let's hit the rook now this I'm gonna
capture like that otherwise there's a
pawn push support this they're gonna
have a Queen trade I don't want to clean
trade oh wait a second pawn push and
then Knight here let's back up pawn push
still okay get my rook here look right
here and then let's do this I want to
stop the pawn breaks can I cast like
it's actually castle what's the time
situation catching up on time pile up
pile up get my darks for Bishop doing
something there dark square bishop uh
not doing anything exciting here we go I
have enough fuel on it get rid of the
knight okay I have enough pieces on it
my queen wants to do something else I
think though doesn't she owe this pawn
push coming up I'll drop in pieces is
his problem
this is winning I'm up on time as well
night is still pinned it's still pinned
and it's unpinned but I'm on this queen
is in a good position
grab a paw and I'm on the Queen if the
knight moves a little scary over here
or a lot scary okay my rep needs to
defend a little bit and I could be
giving check and I got the Queen
actually this is mate no it's not false
alarm
pretty moved back to Chairman 180 188
171 17 seconds I'll just let the clock
tick tick tick tick 183 come on tick
tick tick tick tick tick tick 10 seconds
I just need to go for a quick mate
quick mate there's no quick mate take
here fish up here I'm gonna sneak it in
be sneaky mate mate mate mate Oh what is
it come on give me the show me show me
the chump you confetti show me the money
show me the confetti
what do we got what is it there it is
it's it give me the cam wait for the
confetti the confetti has to come here
it's not official unless the confetti
comes here ah come on
I'm refreshing 188 it says it's
completed looking up here completed but
they're not giving me confetti what did
I do to not deserve that
no confetti I'm never playing in this
tournament again actually it's gonna
happen I'm gonna keep this window open
I'm just gonna keep it off to the side
and I'm gonna celebrate when it happens
I don't know when it's gonna happen but
it's gonna it's gonna happen I'm keeping
this little window around come on if
you're new here what happens is that not
only do you get the little sparkly
trophy but it'll say what place you got
if it's one through three you get
confetti and it's exciting exciting
stuff that's what you play for basically
ah it's just not happening I got first
though saying it right there look at the
standings 188 not without a speed bump
though Oh big speed bump 188 183 171 is
the finish okay ah man
come on let's go let's go give me if I
shake it a little bit shake that it's
not happy I just get the sparkly trophy
they ran out of paper for first place
okay I'm gonna close it out I can't keep
that open actually let me wait another
minute let me just make sure I know
nevermind let's close it out okay